Мінні загородження, колючий дріт і тиша.
Це кордон України з Білоруссю.
Військові, які служать тут, - перші, хто має зустрічати ворога.
Це один зі спостережних пунктів на українсько-білоруському кордоні.
Звідси до території Білорусі буквально кілька десятків метрів.
Тут цілодобово несуть службу українські прикордонники.
Їхня задача - вчасно виявляти та інформувати про рух бронетехніки або захід сюди ворожих диверсійних груп.
Візуальний контроль, спостереження, прослуховування,
своєчасне реагування на зміни в обстановці.
Так описує свої завдання прикордонник Костянтин.
За його словами, поки на цій ділянці тихо.
Надто тихо, якщо порівнювати з російським кордоном, де він служив раніше.
Перебуваючи тут, фізично і морально краще себе почуваєш.
Але все таки ми військовослужбовці і маємо бути постійно напоготові.
Ми їдемо до українсько-російського кордону
на півночі Чернігівської області.
Небезпека там присутня часто,
тому що мають місце обстріли артилерією,
реактивними снарядами - "Градом".
Сюди дістає артилерія, у п'ятикілометровій смузі
біля кордону - міномети.
Останніми місяцями також почали дошкуляти "Ланцети"
і квадрокоптери. Попри все тут живуть люди.
Залишилися там по 20 чоловік, по 10,
по 12 в деяких населених пунктах.
Це люди похилого віку, які не хочуть залишати свої будинки.
Голови громад об'їхали майже всіх людей, які живуть на прикордонні,
запропонували відселення і пропонують виїзд в інші населені пункти.
Люди не погоджуються з виїздом. Ризикують своїм життям.
Від містечка Семенівка - 10 кілометрів до українсько-російського кордону.
Життя тут - як на діжці з порохом.
Ми на кордоні живемо. Ви самі розумієте, що таке кордон.
Періодично стріляють, але все добре.
- Все добре? - Так, усе добре, ми міцніємо.
Обстрілюють кожен день.
Повністю обстріляли по колу всіх,
сіру зону зробили, вибили на 15-20 кілометрів - там нема нікого.
Повибивали, попалили.
А що робити? Куди їхати?
Якби людям дали, куди їхати, а то десь у спортзалі дадуть
і будеш жити, чи що? Куди їхати?
У Семенівці живуть більше семи тисяч людей.
До повномасштабної війни було близько восьми тисяч.
Зараз сюди переїжджають переселенці з сіл під самим кордоном
- вони під постійним вогнем.
Але і в Семенівці регулярно "прилітає".
Порівняно з минулим роком реально вже б'ють по вулицях, прилітає по вулицях.
Тому там, де поприлітало на вулиці, там люди повиїжджали.
Тому що з дітьми це нереально.
Плюс навчання. У нас багато хто їде через навчання,
тому що онлайн - це таке собі навчання.
Один з постачальників відмовився возити товар у цю крамницю,
розповідає продавчиня Марина.
Адже для водіїв це надто небезпечно.
В іншому - життя триває: підвозять продукти, працює лікарня.
Марина разом з десятирічною донькою,
каже, лишатиметься в місті до останнього.
Важко дуже знайти достойну роботу,
щоб покривала і орендну плату, і харчування.
В місті трошки більші видатки, я вважаю.
Але люди - багато хто лишається.
Багато. Тримаються за домівки, тримаються за хати.
Тримаємося, чекаємо нашої перемоги. Дуже чекаємо.
Ще одна постійна небезпека на кордоні - ДРГ.
Від рук російських диверсантів у Семенівській громаді
на початку січня загинув цивільний чоловік.
Цього року російські ДРГ вже п'ять разів
намагалися перетнути кордон.
Українські прикордонники тренуються, аби давати відсіч.
За легендою, ворожа ДРГ змогла зайти на кілька кілометрів углиб української території.
Контрдиверсійна група прочісує місцевість.
Службовий пес допомагає саперам вчасно виявити розтяжку і знешкодити гранату.
Ці військові вже знають, чого чекати від озброєних порушників кордону.
Від звичайних підрозділів регулярної армії
вони відрізняються більш якісною підготовкою і спорядженням.
У них однострій, але він відрізняється від камуфляжу регулярної армії.
Це не рідкісні випадки, коли вони заходять в нашому камуфляжі
- в пікселі чи в мультикамі.
Диверсанти заходять з російської території,
з Білорусі проникнень не було.
Водночас по той бік кордону супротивник теж навчається.
Останні кілька місяців українським військовим
складно проводити глибоку розвідку з повітря.
На суміжній стороні дуже працює ворожа РЕБ.
Вони не дають нам працювати, максимальна висота наших дронів - 120 метрів.
Раніше можна було літати на висоті півтора кілометра - 1500 метрів.
З російського боку кордону перебувають трохи більше 20 тисяч російських військових.
У білоруському прикордонні - 1800 військовослужбовців.
Військові кажуть: цього недостатньо для наступальних дій.
Що буде далі?
Наша розвідка відстежує цю обстановку і своєчасно нас інформує.
Ми своєю чергою у разі зростання військової загрози
звернемося до Генерального штабу ЗСУ,
які передадуть нам додаткові сили.
Якщо на північному кордоні знадобиться підкріплення,
для військових готують оборонні рубежі.
Це кілька ліній інженерних і фортифікаційних споруд.
А також понад пів мільйона протитанкових мін.
Копаються інженерні рови, встановлюються тетраедри
- так звані "зуби дракона",
здійснюється мінування місцевості, копаються траншеї, укриття для особового складу,
бліндажі, встановлюються вогневі споруди.
Вони робляться відповідними цивільними підприємствами за схемами,
затвердженими військовим керівництвом.
Військові інженери постійно моніторять
і присутні під час будівництва для того,
щоб усі роботи були виконані правильно.
Тим часом українські військові на білоруському кордоні
не зводять очей з полів за колючим дротом.
Звідти можна чекати чого завгодно.
Усі, хто служать тут, - завжди напоготові.
Мотивація - в наших людях, у наших громадянах.
Тільки звідти ми черпаємо мотивацію.
Це найцінніше, що в нас є.
Жига, давай поруч.
Ось так. Бажай здоров'я, бажай!
Ось так, ти молодець! Пішли.